on vient voir les [ __ ] comme on va
vous on vient voir des clauses et nous
accaparer leur offre ce qu'il attend des
monstres emporté 1975 dans l'émission un
jour futur
chose rare la parole est donnée aux
travestis en dehors des cabaret dans
leur quotidien dans leur intimité mois
la ville j'en suis fière
ni homme ou femme ni ange ni bête comme
ils disent je suis une créature
mesdames et messieurs voici la créature
série provost 22 ans
signe particulier neuvic la nuit
profession homme d'intérieur femme
d'extérieur et quelle femme sofia bynum
à l'époque les travestis ne sont tolérés
que dans les cabarets pour amuser les
foules mais certains veulent aller au
delà je sais pas pourquoi les gens
comprennent pas ça juste pas ces photos
c'est pas une maladie on a toujours dit
que c'était une maladie mais moi depuis
l'âge de 5 ans j'ai j'ai eu envie de
m'habiller en femme subit en femme j'ai
grandi gt gt une gamine à l'école si tu
veux je t'ai pas un garçon est alors
c'est un état normal pour moi je me
rends compte vis-à-vis de la russe
ils prennent ça comme un état anormal
comme une maladie comme une tare il
faudra attendre les années 80 pour que
la télévision montrent des travestis qui
ne sont pas dans les cabarets
exemple avec le portrait de ce
dessinateur industriel réalisé en 1983
j'ai difficile de rester avec son secret
de dire on jetait vraiment qu'en s'y
rende ce besoin d'autres femmes à l'âge
de 9 ans
les travestis ne sont plus cantonnées au
monde du spectacle et certains abordent
le sujet de la transsexualité et des
opérations
dans les années 90 alors que le
phénomène drag queen émergent en france
le changement s'opère aussi dans la
société
la preuve ce lancement de ce journaliste
jacques homme en lui une part de
féminité
chaque femme a en elle une part de
masculinité et oui et oui vous le savez
vous qui nous regardent et absolument
et il y à des hommes et des femmes qui
ont voté vont lui aller plus loin et
qu'ils portent
extérieurement les signe de la féminité
pourquoi et bien parce que ça leur fait
plaisir
[Musique]